hi I'm Ronald I al from the Boston
Consulting Group I live in New York but
think of myself as an East Asian East
Asia has the potential over the next
five to ten years to contribute well
over half of the world's growth this
increase in contribution of East Asia is
also going to create dynamism is going
to create companies that are world
leaders it's going to create an
opportunity to innovate and really lead
the world and demonstrate what is
possible in this the East Asian
companies East Asian corporates East
Asian governments are really going to
set the stage for what is really
possible in the world of the future